>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Linda Zachrison: Jonas Hassen
Khemiri in his debut novel
"Ett oga rott," "One Red Eye," hit
the Swedish literary scene in 2003
and was praised for its comment on
the present and changing society
with its playful language,
humor, satire, and fast pace.
Ever since then, Jonas has received
a number of awards for his novels,
for his short stories and
plays in Sweden and abroad.
He has now written four novels
and six plays and the latest play,
Everything-- no, the latest novel,
"Everything I Don't Remember,"
was awarded with the Sweden's
most prestigious literary prize,
the August Prize, named
after Strindberg, of course.
Jonas Hassen Khemiri often shifts
perspectives in his writing
and invites the reader to come
and play with him and his--
and to play with his
electrified language of his own
but even got a name for
itself, called Khemirian.
His work has been translated
into 23 languages
and his plays have been performed
by over a hundred companies
around the world.
Right now, his play, "I
Call My Brothers," is staged
at the Forum Theatre here
in Washington and it runs
until October 1st,
so you better hurry.
A couple of years ago, Jonas wrote
an open letter to the Minister
of Justice in Sweden who had
publicly defended racial profiling
in the subways of Stockholm.
It was called "Dear Beatrice."
It became the most shared piece
in Swedish social media history
with 250,000 shares
only the first day,
and it started a Tweeter
movement where people
under the #dearbeatrice started
sharing their own stories.
Jonas encourages us all to
look behind the surface,
behind our prejudices,
and behind our fear.
You can all support the
festival with a gift or donation
and the festival would not be
possible without the support
of sponsors and book lovers.
Just a few more things, please turn
your cellphones off and I also want
to tell you that Q&A will
follow after Jonas' talk.
So, save your questions.
Also, be aware that if you ask
question, you will be filmed
for the archives and that you can
meet Jonas also after the talk
when he will do signing,
starting at 4:30.
Now, please join me in welcoming
from Sweden, Jonas Hassen Khemiri.
[ Applause ]
>> Jonas Hassen Khemiri:
Does that work?
Even though I'm too
tall for this podium.
Do you hear me OK if
I speak like this?
Great. So thank you very much for
that very kind introduction, Linda.
I do have to say, if my
mother is watching this,
that she was not a librarian
but she was a physiotherapist
and she was very much
a lover of books.
I have some kind of idea of how
I'm going to structure this.
The plan is that I will start to
talk a little bit about memories
and what memories do to us and
I will do that because the--
my latest novel that was
published in the States is called
"Everything I Don't Remember."
A few years ago, I went
to my grandmother's house
and I started finding these kind
of weird small handwritten notes.
I would go there every
weekend and I would visit her
and I would see small
scribblings in her house.
So what she-- The first
thing I found was
like small yellow Post-It notes
where she had written like salt
on the box where she keeps
salt or sugar on the sugar box.
And I was kind of taken aback.
I wasn't sure what she was doing
because I recognize her handwriting.
My grandmother was a
retired teacher of Swedish
so she had this very antiquated
and beautiful handwriting.
After when I realized that she was
writing these kind of small notes
as a way to try to find stability
because her memories were
slowly starting to fade.
I specifically remember
once when I got there
and she had written two Post-Its on
her phone and on her remote control
because they looked so very similar.
So on the phone, she
had written phone
and on the remote control,
she had written TV.
Because I realized when
she was watching TV
and someone would call
her, she often tried
to respond in the remote, you know.
Or if she tried to raise the
volume, she tried to use the phone.
So, these electronic devices were
a little bit too similar so she had
to separate them by using her words.
And this shift, when the
memories started fading,
it went really quickly for
her to start to become more
and more insecure about
who she was and who we were
who were surrounding her.
The next step was that she-- I
was-- I would be at home sleeping
and I would wake up in the middle
of the night and she would--
I would see that it was my
grandma calling me like 2
or 3 in the morning and
I would always respond
because I'm being a little worried,
you know, something might happened.
And always when I responded,
she was so happy.
That was her first
reaction, like extreme joy,
and she was like Jonas,
are you awake?
And then I'm just, well,
not really, you know.
She was [inaudible] because
that meant that she was not,
you know, awake by herself.
And then she-- her next thing was
that she just wants to check whether
or not my number was my number.
So she said the number like she
had just dialed and just wanted
to check that that was me.
And I said yes, that's me.
And she said thank you.
Then I can go back to sleep
feeling a little bit more comforted.
So, she used the languages
and the numbers in order
to find some kind of stability.
That summer, she became a
little bit unsure who I was.
In the fall, she-- for the first
time I went there and she saw me
and became afraid seeing me because
she didn't recognize me at all.
And in the spring, she could
not stay in her house so we had
to move her to a house
for people with dementia.
And this experience created
this question of who we are
without our memories, because it
was-- that was my grandmother.
Like every time I went there, I
can see that she looked the same,
she had the same facial
features, the same perfume.
We talked about the same things.
She was-- Since she was a retired
teacher, she had very clear ideas
about everything, especially
how to reform the school system.
She knows exactly how to do that.
She also had quite a lot of opinions
about my authorship and my writing.
I remember once, I asked her what
she thought about my first book
and she said-- very
quickly, she said, well,
I like you, you know, I like you.
And it-- for a moment, it really
sounded as if she said I like it
and I was kind of clinging on to
the idea that she said I like it.
But no, I like you.
You know, you're my eldest
grandchild, you know, so.
Because there were kind
of a lot of swear words
and curse words in that book.
And she also thought that I--
sometimes that I kind of--
that I didn't write the truth.
She like the truth and I
should stick to the truth.
That was her thing.
These thoughts and questions about
memory and who we are without them
and specifically I remember thinking
at some point she will end--
she will stop being my grandmother.
So, if she has 80% of her memories,
of course, she's my grandmother.
If she has 40, yes,
it's still her, right?
I recognize her.
But if she has 20,
5%, is that still her?
All these questions kind of
trickled down into this latest novel
that is called "Everything
I Don't Remember."
In that novel, there is a
grandmother who is losing her memory
and who was very upset that someone
has taken her driving license.
There's also a house
that has been left.
And but then, in the center of the
novel is a young man called Samuel.
And Samuel-- The book
starts off with a car crash.
It's not at all spoiler
but we find out very early
on in the book that Samuel is dead.
Samuel has taken his grandmother's
car and he has driven it
into a tree outside of Stockholm,
in an area called Vastberga.
A writer, who is a little
bit reminiscent of the writer
that you see in front of you right
now, hears about this car crash
and becomes obsessed with trying
to find out what really happened.
So what was behind this car crash?
Was it a suicide, was
it an accident,
was it due to the long relationship
that Samuel had had with Laide,
was it because of economic conflict
with his friend Vandad,
what happened?
That's the mystery
that drives this novel.
So the writer starts contacting
everyone who remembers Samuel
and tries to ask them
who Samuel really was.
So we get to know his friends,
his family, his neighbors.
The plan is to try
to map what happens--
happened during Samuel's
last day alive.
The problem is the people are not
really remembering the same things.
So there's kind of a friction
between the different
ideas of who Samuel was.
For example, some people claim that
in the story, there is this kind
of big love affair
between Samuel and Laide.
Some people say that that's--
that was like a, you know,
this kind of Hollywood
version love affair,
that that is what explained
why he passed away.
And according to Laide who was
the-- involved in this relationship,
it was more like a fling.
It was nothing.
It was not a big thing
as some people claim.
So, the different versions of the
story are kind of being tested
and being conflicted
throughout the novel.
And the more we read without
like spoiling anything,
I could say that the writer
himself has kind of a secret agenda
to why he wants to
collect all these memories.
And towards the end, we realize
maybe he and Samuel has--
have more in common
that he wants to reveal.
So in the center of the novel,
there's Samuel who is a young man
who is super fascinated
with the memory.
Specially, he is fascinated with
how to make people remember him.
So, on the first date with Laide, he
has this long argument where he says
that the best way to get
people to remember you is
to make them associate you with
their daily routine, right.
So if I'm going to make you remember
me, I should make you associate--
I should make you associate me with
something that you do every day.
And Laide is a little bit-- she
doesn't really believe this theory.
She said, well, the main thing if
you want to remember someone is,
of course, you create
some kind of emotion.
But Samuel is not too
big on emotions.
He's more into like creating
different systems of his own.
So he says, well, the smartest thing
for you to remember me that would be
if I can make you associate
me with water.
And then Samuel takes a glass
of water and he pours it
onto himself kind of,
with the ambition to kind
of force her not to forget him.
Another important person in the book
is Laide who's the ex-girlfriend
of Samuel's.
And then the third important
person is his best friend, Vandad,
who is a super loyal friend who some
people claim that he does everything
for money but he says that
he doesn't care about money.
But he's one of those persons
who says that quite lot.
You know, people say like,
well, I don't care about money.
Money is nothing.
Like I don't care, but
like it doesn't matter
who pays or who doesn't pay.
But in a way, you know, it's only
money but he keeps coming back
to the issue of money
throughout the novel.
So these are the three characters.
And then there is the
grandmother, of course,
that was losing her memory.
The form of the novel
is structured in a way
so that we're not totally sure
100% of the time who is speaking.
And I've always enjoy that
feeling, when I'm reading myself,
I'm not really sure if the words
that I'm being presented with,
if they come from a man or a woman
or someone who is old or young,
because that makes me kind of
see my own preconceived ideas,
my own prejudice.
So in the novel, these different
voices, these different memories
of Samuel are being kind of--
they're being thrown back and forth
between different perspectives
on this person
who is not alive anymore.
Do you have Lego here in the States?
Lego? I was a big-- I love
that reaction, oh my God, yeah.
So, Lego, when I was a kid,
I was a big Lego fan, right,
and I know that's a
very tired metaphor
for like constructing something but
that's like-- that is my feeling.
When I encounter a book
that I really love,
my feeling is that I'm being
presented with some kind
of like big sea of Lego bits and
it's up to me to put them together.
That-- Hopefully if this novel
works, that is the feeling
that I want you to have to like--
that you are the ones who are kind
of creating Samuel and hopefully
that gives you some kind of feeling
that Samuel exists in a 3D form.
There's another character
in the novel who is not--
who is voiceless, and that
character is my hometown, Stockholm.
I came back to Stockholm after
having spent a few years abroad
in 2010 and I felt
my city had changed.
One of the inspirations
came from a friend of mine
who had a job one summer to drive
one of those kind of tourist trains
that looked like toys,
have you seen them?
So it's like a-- it looks like a--
it kind of like a huge toy train
where tourists go on this train
and he would drive the tourists
around the highlights so they could
see the highlights of Stockholm.
And during this ride, they
had a prerecorded voiceover
that said all these terrible cliches
about what Stockholm was, of course.
Like, oh, Stockholm, it's the
Venice of the North, you know.
Stockholm, it's beautiful.
And it was up to my friend to
kind of drive with exact speed
so that the, you know, voice
met up with what they saw.
Because what happens otherwise,
then we have a voice who's kind
of dislocated, a voice that
can come from anywhere.
So, his ambition was to drive.
When we pass the rich area of
Ostermalm, the voice had to say,
"Look, this is the
affluent area of Ostermalm."
When the train cross the bridge, the
voice would say, "Wow, Stockholm,
the Venice of the North,
water everywhere," you know.
And then the train
would stop like on a--
high up on a hill so you saw
the beautiful view of Stockholm
and the voice said, "Stockholm,
look at her, isn't she beautiful?"
[ Laughter ]
And my friend said, I'm going crazy.
I will not take it.
I hate that voice.
[ Laughter ]
And I was like why?
Well, because it only
tells one story.
It tells the people who are
visiting our city one version
of what we have in this city.
Of course, there's a view,
there's water, there's--
there are areas that are very rich,
but what about my neighborhood,
where are the experiences
that I have of this city.
That's my friend was like.
He kept saying this through in
the whole summer and he was like,
one day, I'm going
to hijack that train.
[ Laughter ]
I'm going to just take it
and I'm just going to drive
to the area where I grew up.
So every time the voice says,
"Wow, look, the most affluent area
of Stockholm," they
would see his background.
And whenever this, you know, if they
would say-- the voice would say,
"Wow, it's the Venice of the North,"
they would see the mall, you know,
where he hang out in the weekend.
And do you think he did it?
Do you think at one point he took
that train and went for a joy ride?
Because what happens if you do that?
You get fired right there, economic
consequences of making that choice.
So he kept saying I'm going
to do it, I'm going to--
just wait one day, one day.
And I was just like,
have you done it?
Tuesday, I'm going
to do it, Tuesday.
I'm just waiting for the right day.
Finally, he never did.
They did, of course, he kept driving
his route because it's very--
to make that kind of rebellion,
you have to face consequences.
And oftentimes, it's easier to make
those kind of rebellions in theory
than to do them in practice.
So Stockholm was a big inspiration.
When I came back to Stockholm, I
had this idea, I had the feeling
that my city had changed because
everyone was talking about economy,
that it was as if economy
had come seep
into the veins of my--
even my friends.
I would sit with friends who
I know were big book lovers.
Normally, we talk about
Calvino, Fortner or Baldwin.
And now, all of a sudden, they
were speaking about mortgages
and how much they're going to
invest in a certain apartment
sell it for and renovate it.
And I remember thinking,
that's never going to be me
because I'm above economy, right.
I deal with the high arts.
My book is for sale
afterwards, you see.
[ Laughter ]
No, but that's not part
of me because I'm above.
I have my own system, my own--
I can just liberate myself
with the use of my imagination.
Then, I became a father.
And I wrote this open letter that
became a very viral thing in Sweden
and that got a lot of love but also
got a lot of quite harsh attacks
from certain right-wing
powers in Stockholm.
And all of a sudden, I became the
person who was focused on mortgages.
And all of a sudden, I was a person
who realized that if it comes
to paying a price for security,
I would be ready to do anything.
If-- It's up to me to put my
family in like in a secured place.
I would pay anything
to make that happen.
So all of a sudden, I was like
sitting there with, you know,
comparing different interest rates
and feeling economy entering my body
but also kidnapping my eyes, because
the city that I knew from growing
up was not the city that I saw.
All of a sudden, I saw a city full
of potential investments, you know.
And I hated that part of me but
I could really see it happening,
how kind of the numbers and
the economy kind of, yeah,
almost became part of my DNA.
So I think that's why the novel
deals a lot with economics.
In the center, we have three
people are trying to get close
to each other but economy and
numbers are kind of making
that impossible, you could say.
So, with this book, I
had it kind of like--
it started off in a very
light place and I'm--
now I'm going to do something
which maybe is not a good idea
because I'm in Washington DC.
But I-- I'm trying to frame it in a
way so you won't-- no, but when I--
I'm going to say it like this.
When my father-- he had a big
vinyl collection and he had a lot
of soul music in that collection,
like Marvin Gaye, Otis Redding,
Aretha Franklin, and I remember
listening to those records as a kid,
really enjoying the
music, but kind of thinking
that the words were a little
bit like lame, you know.
And he is like the--
because isn't, I think,
Marvin Gaye is from
Washington, right?
>> Detroit.
>> Jonas Hassen Khemiri: Detroit?
>> [Simultaneously] Washington.
>> Jonas Hassen Khemiri: I'm
sorry, you're outnumbered.
The thing is this book
started with the ambition
to write a very happy kind
of love story, and it started
with an investigation of
curiosity if I would be ready
to actually write down cliches.
Because when I was a kid, I
remember listening to like
"Ain't no mountain high enough,
ain't no valley low enough.
Nothing can stop me from getting to
you," and I kind of yawn and thought
that was, come on, Marvin,
that's not how you write
interesting fiction.
Like you have to use
words that are more--
that are not as lame, kind of.
Cliches don't work.
And then I fell in love the
first time and I listened
to this same song, "Ain't
no mountain high enough,
ain't no valley low
enough," and all of a sudden,
I felt like that's really true.
That's exactly what it feels like.
[ Laughter ]
And of course, nothing had changed.
The song was there.
The text was exactly the
same, but I had changed.
And when you're in this kind
of strong emotional
states, cliches come alive.
And I wanted to see if I would be
ready to kind of actually write
down what it feels to be in love.
I wasn't sure if I would
be able to do that.
I wanted to try it.
So that was the starting point
of the novel, to write this kind
of "ain't no mountain
high enough" novel.
Then life intervened.
I was writing, I was
having a grand all the time,
Laide and Samuel met each other.
Samuel poured the water over him.
Fiction was being created.
But then, as I was writing,
I had the experience of--
I had a friend who passed away
while I was writing this book.
And then all of a sudden, everything
that I was writing felt empty.
There was no point
in writing anymore.
But my first reaction
when I heard that call--
when I got the call and said she's
not alive anymore, all right,
my first impulse was I'm
going to write her back.
I'm going to take everything
I remember of that person
and make her permanent
through my memories, kind of.
I wrote a short text, I
read it at her funeral.
Did that make her come alive?
No. Was she in that text?
Maybe a fragment of what
was her was in that text.
But she was not there.
She was maybe even more void.
The void of her maybe became even
bigger the more I wrote about her.
So I think that also
influenced this novel
because when a young person
dies, what happens to everyone
who is left, at least in my
experience, is this giant question
of what could I have
done differently,
and I think that's
what all the characters
in the book are dealing with,
like could I have called more,
called less, what would have
happened if I did so and so.
So I think that's why the
characters are also clinging
on to their version of Samuel
because it's their way of, yeah,
their way-- maybe their way
of convincing themselves
that they did not do anything wrong.
And the second thing that happened
while I was writing was this
experience that I started
off with telling you
about with my grandmother when she,
in a very quick just a few months,
started losing her memories.
And in order for you to
get some kind of idea to--
what I found interesting
with that experience was
that she always return to the words
and the numbers and her handwriting
and even the expressions.
Those became her kind
of emergency exit.
Those became the things
that she clung on to
in order to re-find herself.
So no matter how-- when--
before she became sick,
she always used-- she
had this saying.
She always used to say "I'm
not stubborn, I'm not stubborn,
I'm not stubborn, I'm not
stubborn, but I never gave in."
[ Laughter ]
And that was very much her.
So, she starts losing her memories.
The fog enters into her
body and she disappears.
She's no longer the
person that I remember
and she doesn't remember me.
But even when she was in her
home towards the end of her life,
even when she was in a
constant state of terror
because she didn't recognize
anyone or anything around her,
that saying kept coming back.
Like she said the same words, "I'm
not stubborn, I'm not stubborn,
I'm not stubborn, but
I never gave in."
So I would like to
end with reading--
actually, I had the idea that I'm
not going to read from the novel,
I'm going to read from
a short text that I kind
of started off the novel.
I think of this text as a
rocket launcher, rocket launcher
or rocket kind of a rocket
something for the novel.
What is it called, the thing
that is around the rocket?
>> A launching pad.
>> Jonas Hassen Khemiri: A
launching pad, thank you.
So, this is the launching pad of
the novel, and it's a short piece
that I-- it started off with a
newspaper in Sweden that wanted--
that asked me if I wanted
to write like a review
from a music festival in Sweden.
And I went to that festival and
I borrowed my grandmother's car.
I went to the festival
and then I came back
and then I couldn't write a
review about the music festival
because my heart was somewhere else.
I was only thinking about the fact
that my grandmother was
slowly losing her memories.
So, instead of writing a review,
I wrote a text called
"Grandma's Mitsubishi."
The newspaper printed it but they
were a little bit confused of it
and they were like not 100%
amused, a little bit more confused.
But I'm going to try to read that
text and then I will be happy
to answer any questions
that you might have.
Just-- I will actually-- I will
read just a short section in Swedish
because Swedish is my
mother tongue and just
so you hear what it
sounds like in Swedish.
And then I will read the
whole thing through in English
and then we do questions.
[ Foreign Language ]
I go to grandma's house to return
her car and would sit in her kitchen
and drink coffee from the new coffee
maker that only costs 200 krona,
200, even though it's a Philips
and Philips is a good brand
because it's Swedish, grandma says,
smiling so that her gold
fillings in her teeth gleam.
She's wearing her flattery
blue blouse
and a pearl necklace
with matching earrings.
And as long as she's
sitting down, you don't think
about how she only has
one shoe and no skirt.
But my skirt is around
here somewhere.
Hold on, I'll get it, grandma says.
And she gets up and walks over
to the stove and stands there
for a few seconds before she goes
into the pantry and comes back
with a big pack carton
full of cookies.
They've taken my driver's
license, she says
and then we sit there in silence.
We drink coffee and eat cookies
and they taste almost
exactly as I remember.
So, you can imagine that you're
the newspaper agents, you know,
kind of waiting for some
kind of festival action.
But here it comes, just.
I tell her about the music
festival I went to in Gothenburg.
James Blake's completely
magical concert
in Annedal Church, goosebumps.
Prince's is a big show with
purple confetti, dancing pains.
I baked these cookies a long
time ago, grandma replies,
long before they took
my driver's license.
I tell her about the high energy Wiz
Khalifa concert, hands in the air,
and their super boring MF
Doom session, yawn attack.
But I'm not going to
give up, grandma says.
I'm going to appeal.
They can't lock me up in here.
On the last night, we went to
kind of weird Kanye West concert,
I say, do you know who that is?
Kanye West, is he Japanese,
grandma answers.
No, American.
He had like 20 female
ballet dancers on the stage
and then extravagant laser show
and fireworks and smoke machines,
but the only thing that
was good about his show was
when he accidentally
showed he was human.
Like when he lost his place
during a memorized interlude
about how important it
is to follow your dreams.
All this time, he sneaked a
peek up at his image on one
of the big screens to check
himself out in the middle of a song.
Then he was transformed from being
a superstar to being a human being.
But those people aren't
human, grandma says.
Who? The people who took
my driver's license.
And every time grandma says
those, she uses that tone
that is impossible to misunderstand.
Those people, those damn people,
those people that seemed capable
of absolutely anything, those people
who cut pensions without remembering
who it was who built this country,
those people who don't have
the slightest idea of how
to impose order and control
in school classrooms,
those people who shut down the gas
station in the corner and turned it
into a graveyard for
rusting ventilation ducts,
yellow insulation foam,
and broken coffee machines.
And yet, the worse thing of all
is that those people decided,
with no warning whatsoever, that
grandma is no longer allowed
to drive her own gray Mitsubishi,
while she has been driving
for over 40 years and has never
ever been involved in an accident.
But there had actually been a few
accidents over the years, I say.
Yes, of course, says grandma,
a few but not very many
and none of them were fatal.
[ Laughter ]
And that's true.
Grandma is right.
She has never been involved
in a fatal accident,
if you don't count the deer.
But recently, during
the last few years,
the number of minor incidents
has increased more and more.
Like the time grandma picked
up my brother from the airport
in the countryside and turned out
to the parking lot and then tried
to drive straight through
a roundabout.
But it was extremely foggy that day.
Or like the time grandma got a
hole in her fog light after running
into a carelessly placed broom.
Or the time grandma was
involved in three crashes
in one year on the Liljeholm Bridge.
But none of them were
my fault, grandma says.
And I agree.
The first time, there was an idiot
who honked at her at a red light.
And since she had dozed off, she
became frightened and happened
to run into the car in front of her.
The second time she had
ended up in the wrong lane
and an idiotic bus driver
refused to let her by.
And the third crash wasn't
even on the Liljeholm Bridge,
it was just past it
on the Arsta side.
A deer was running alongside road
and suddenly without warning,
the deer swerved to the
left and flung itself
across the hood of grandma's car.
Some people, the witnesses,
the insurance company,
the police report claimed that
grandma ran into the deer.
She didn't.
It was the deer that
flung itself onto her car.
You could almost call
it a suicide attempt,
grandma says because she could
see that the deer had sad eyes,
drooping antlers, and a
general air of depression.
When the-- Before I published
this, I went to grandma's house.
I sat in front of her and I read
this text because the whole point
of this text is to
get her to understand
that she has to let us help us.
Like she has done everything
throughout her life,
she's always helped us,
but she can't ask for help.
So the whole point of this text is
just you have to let us help you.
As I'm reading this, I'm thinking
that she's going to interrupt me
and say something like, come on,
that's a little bit
over the top, you know.
That's like your first
novel, kind of.
But she stopped me after-- I
was reading about the deer,
she stopped me and she
put her hand at me,
her hand on mine and
she said, "Jonas."
I was like, "Yeah?"
"That's the best thing
you've ever written."
[ Laughter ]
It was exactly like that.
And it was.
Like in her memory of that
incident, it was exactly like that.
Because if it had been any
other way, she would be forced
to change her idea of who she was
and then things would get tricky.
When the coffee is gone, we say
goodbye and I hide the car keys
where she can't find them
way up high on the hat rack.
Later that afternoon, she calls
and asks when I'm going to come
by with the car or whether I
had fun at the music festival.
She calls again that
evening and asks
if I'm coming by with the car soon.
We can drink coffee,
we can eat cookies.
I'm curious to hear what it was
like at that festival in Gothenburg.
The next day, she calls at dawn
and asks when I'm going to pick her
up so we can drive up to Stockholm.
She doesn't want to be
in the country anymore.
She wants to go home.
She feels isolated.
But grandma, I say, you're
already in Stockholm.
You are home.
Can't you tell?
You're calling me from
your regular home number.
You're lying in your
regular old bed.
And if you just look
a little to the right,
you can see a regular old night
stand, with the old Vademecum bottle
and a glass of water
and the tattered Bible
and the blinking clock radio.
And right next to the bed is the
note you've written to yourself.
Your beautiful, ornate handwriting
that says, "I am in Stockholm.
I'm not going anywhere."
And grandma finds the note and
reads the words and says, "Oh,
I guess I'm starting
to get a bit nutty."
And we hung up and I persuade
myself that my memories are eternal
and I will never need
to write something
down for it to remain with me.
My phone is quiet for 10
minutes before it rings again
and it's grandma wanting
to know when I'm coming
by to drop off the car and how
it went at that music festival
in Gothenburg and I say the
music festival was totally wicked
and magical and I'm so glad
you decided to come along.
It was so fun to see you rocking
out to Prince hits and clapping
in time with Wiz Khalifa.
And I'm sure you remember, you
remember, right, how the audience
in that church cheered when
you climbed up on stage
to sing the second verse of
James Blake's encore song, right?
And grandma is quiet for a few
seconds and then she says, "Oh,
now you're just making things up."
But you can hear that
she is smiling.
Thank you very much for coming
and if there are any questions,
I'd be happy to answer them.
[ Applause ]
So I'm being told by a sign
that we have five minutes,
if there are any questions or--
>> I wanted to say that I
love what you say about memory
and when we're losing our memory.
I watched my mother go through
that and I just think that the--
all the different ways you looked
at it and the ways that you looked
at what makes up a human being
from all the perspectives
is just very moving.
Thank you very much.
>> Jonas Hassen Khemiri:
I'm really happy to hear that.
[ Applause ]
Yes.
>> I was intrigued by what you
said about returning to Stockholm
and the emphasis on the economy.
And I was wondering how you've seen
economic issues impact not only your
own work but the work of
other Swedish novelists
who are your contemporaries
and why you think those might
be surprising as a theme.
>> Jonas Hassen Khemiri: I
think-- that's a great question.
I think maybe I had-- I was more--
I was quite-- how should I put it.
I'm a failed economist.
Like I have studied economy when
I was young and I never graduated
which my father reminds
me about every 10 minutes.
But I've always been
fascinated with the kind
of the power that money
can give you.
And I think the money-- the power
and the privilege that
money can give you.
So, since I became a father,
I had this kind of theme.
My latest play was called "Almost
Equal To" and that also deals
with economy and kind of
the challenges of knowing
that there's a system that has
all these negative consequences,
but not really knowing how
to formulate an alternative.
And I think that I-- before I became
a father, I think I had this idea
that I could be free to create
in my fictional universe.
But I think becoming a father,
to think I realize that my idea
of economics were quite-- was
quite simplified actually,
that it was very tricky to create
this kind of separate universe from,
yeah, the everyday
reality in Stockholm.
And like the main shift that has
happened in Stockholm is that we--
the latest 10 and 20 years, we've
changed the whole housing market.
So, we've gone from a rent-based
system to now we can actually invest
in housing which creates all this--
all kinds of interesting
consequences,
not only for the people who-- like
I had the luxury of being able
to find a secure place
for my family.
But it was also interesting
to see how
that changed my view of my own city.
Because if you had the
illusion that you can own a part
of a physical space, the people
who don't have that ability,
you start seeing them as with
a suspicion that I was, yeah,
that I didn't think that I was
capable with that, kind of.
Yeah.
>> Oh, you want to go first?
>> Jonas Hassen Khemiri: Yeah.
>> Oh, OK.
My question is how long did
it take you to write the book
and how do you find the
strength to write again
when your friend dies
and you feel empty?
How do you move on and keep writing?
Do you stop?
How do you, I guess, get to
starting and completing a book?
>> Jonas Hassen Khemiri:
Well, this one was trickier
than the other ones, actually.
And I think it had to do
with that feeling that I've--
so I've been writing all my life.
That has been my main joy, like
the best drug I know is to--
just to go home and
to write and to--
I've never doubted
the value of words.
But having that loss in my life, for
the first time, it was as if I kind
of doubted what words
could do actually.
And I don't think I have a-- the one
thing that got me out of that whole
of feeling like doubting what
words could do was just to realize
that even though they
couldn't, how should I put it,
even though they couldn't
recreate the person who was gone,
the feelings that I had of having
lost her were able to capture--
I was able to put that on the
page, and there were many things
that happened after having lost her
that I thought would be
tricky to put in post.
One thing that was weird to me that
we all know if we lose someone,
that person is gone, but
the strange thing was
that even though she was gone,
she was present everywhere.
So I kept seeing her everywhere,
I kept just speaking my memories
like the amounts of
memories that kept coming
up that we had shared
was just endless.
So, the only way I had-- the only
way I could deal with that was
to try to write myself
out of it and, yeah.
In the end, it became
this book, but--
>> OK.
>> Jonas Hassen Khemiri: Now, I'm
seeing a sign that says wrap up
and I'm guessing that that
means that we are done.
So thank you very much for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.